et sur le plan économique à présent le
feu vert de bruxelles au plan de relance
de la france la présidente de la
commission européenne vient à paris
aujourd'hui pour valider ce plan de 40
milliards d'euros elle aura un entretien
avec le chef de l'état un plan daide
européen qui s'ajoute au plan de relance
national de 100 milliards d'euros
la france est le troisième bénéficiaire
derrière l'espagne et l'italie
ce plan sera financé pour la première
fois par un emprunt des états ce qui
leur impose certaines contraintes
on en parle justement ce matin dans dans
l'édito échos de jean marc sylvestre
[Musique]
bonjour cher jean-marc heureuse de vous
retrouver dans dans la matinale adhère t
france alors 40 milliards ça n'est pas
rien c'est encore de l'argent magique
qui qui est qui vient d'où cet argent et
qui va aller où précisément de l'argent
magique venant de bruxelles
rien n'est moins sûr non cet argent en
fait correspond vous le disiez à la part
française du plan de relance qui avait
été décidé par les dirigeants de l'union
européenne pour lutter contre les effets
de la crise pandémique alassane ça
remonte déjà à pas mal de temps puisque
tous avaient été décidés il ya plus de
six mois le plan est très en retard mais
quand même il est assez intéressant
d'abord parce qu'il est important en
volume il porte au total sur 750
milliards d'euros qui vont venir
s'ajouter à tout ce que les pays membres
ont déjà libéré chacun de leur côté
ensuite c'est intéressant parce que ce
plan sera financé par des emprunts
européens par des euro obligations
et ça c'est la première fois finalement
que les états membres se mettent
d'accord pour emprunter ensemble pour
être solidaire garantir un emprunt dont
le produit sera distribuée redistribuer
ensuite aux états membres actuellement
l'italie la france l'allemagne c'est un
signal politique vers plus de solidarité
au sein de l'union ça a été compliqué ça
a été pénible ça a été difficile mais en
fait on vient donc bien d'en toucher les
dividendes alors le profit de cet
emprunt sera banques il est entre les
selles les vingt-sept mille et ventilé à
condition que les projets
d'investissement contribuer à
l'investissement digital à la mutation
écologique
la réindustrialisation des économies
européennes et à la correction des
effets sociaux delà de la pandémie alors
il ya effectivement globalement un
certain nombre de conditions que
bruxelles met à l'utilisation de cet
argent est ce que ça veut dire que la
france a rempli ces conditions alors au
départ c'est vrai chaque pays devait
prendre des engagements fermes des
engagements de sérieux notamment en
matière de dépenses publiques et de
réformes de structure en fait on
s'aperçoit que sa commission de môssieur
halak a été assez cool contre eu des
événements et des climats politiques
avec la france puisque bruxelles ne
conditionnent finalement pas cette aide
à la mise en place de réformes de ce que
bruno le maire s'est engagé à consacrer
une grande part 50% du clan français
pour l'écologie et 25% pour le numérique
en espèces sonnantes et trébuchantes
ben ça veut dire que la france va
récupérer au total 40 milliards qui
viennent financer presque la moitié des
100 milliards prévus au titre de la
relance de sortie de crise donc vous
avez compris confère encore beaucoup de
politiques aux finances du numérique de
l'écologie vous allez me dire c'est très
à la mode non il ya des besoins évidents
mais mais bruxelles ne pose pas de
conditions pouvait s'attendre par
exemple à ce que bruxelles nous impose
de finaliser la fameuse loi de réforme
des retraites qui va coûter un peu
d'argent ou et qui est très celle qui
est assez urgente et qu'on n'arrive pas
à faire politiquement ou alors des plans
de réduction des dépenses sociales afin
de réduire la dette publique colossale
qui a été accumulée depuis le début de
la pandémie et qui dépasse aujourd'hui
120 % du pib cette année mais rodin
compris que bruxelles allait éviter
d'imposer des directives contraignantes
qui sont très mal vécu et ça fait assez
impopulaire compte tenu du climat anti
un peu anti européen qui circule un peu
dans la communauté aujourd'hui dans
l'union et concrètement que comment est
ce que la france va t-elle utiliser cet
argent jean marc alors c'est vraiment
halal à vous avez raison c'est vraiment
la bonne question parce que les
entreprises du numérique
bah elles l ont pas de problème pour
lever des fonds privés afin d'assurer
leur développement à elles font appel à
l'epal mais on pourra toujours investir
dans la recherche oui parce qu'on en a
besoin dans l'équipement des
particuliers la pandémie et le
télétravail par exemple ont creusé des
inégalités entre ceux qui étaient
correctement équipés et ceux qui
n'étaient pas là
acturevue méric s'est aggravée alors on
peut essayer de réduire cette fracture
en incitant les gens à s'équiper
les allocations de fonds seront beaucoup
plus difficiles au bénéfice de
l'écologie pourquoi parce qu'il existe
quantité de lobby d'associations
universités et d'actions vous avez bien
vu chacun à son ami sur ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour lutter contre le
climat et pour améliorer l'environnement
mais même la question est de savoir si
on finance des incitations fiscales à la
consommation à la consommation verte
c'est ce qui se passe dans l'automobile
aujourd'hui on a un plan massif de
conversion de l'automobile à l'économie
allait à l'automobile électrique mais
c'est quand même le contribuable qui
paye c'est sur les fonds publics ou
alors si on investit massivement dans
l'énergie décarbonée c'est à dire et là
on va retomber sur le nucléaire et on
risque de réveiller des débats
politiques difficiles à gérer
non on aurait besoin ce qui vient on
aurait besoin d'un véritable plan
stratégie qu'il ne se fixe pas de
directives et d'obligations certes mais
qui définisse clairement ce qui relève
de l'état des collectivités locales
surtout du marché dans la poursuite des
normes et des objectifs auxquels on
s'est engagé ce qui est curieux
aujourd'hui je fatigue vous avez
remarqué mais nous l'avions remarqué
c'est au président de la république
avait cru bon de réveiller le
commissariat au plan le marché peut
avoir besoin d'éclairage de longue
portée d'incitation les responsables
politiques aussi ont besoin libre accès
mais après six mois le nomination
on peut se demander ce que va faire le
commissaire au plan
ilan locaux il a des voitures il a des
collaborateurs
mais pour l'instant on n'a pas vu
beaucoup d'idées sortir merci beaucoup
jean-marc pour toutes ces précisions
c'était l édito échos de la matinale